so good morning everyone
it is 9:00 a.m. on the west coast and
I'm now it's very co-director at the
bd2k centers Coordination Center so last
time in this series we completed our
discussions on data modeling and
inference and today we kind of shift
gears to talk about some other topics of
interest in biomedical big data so the
first topic we'll be covering is one of
during interest open science questions
around making science transparent and
reproducible and of making it available
has important implications not just
within the academic and scientific
communities but to the broader public
and with us today is dr. Brian Nozik who
is professor psychology at University of
Virginia dr. nosik is co-founder and
executive director of the center of open
science which advocates and supports the
practice of open science on a global
scale in 2015 he was named on nature's
10 list and he's also in The Chronicle
of Higher Education influence list Brian
thank you so much for joining us this
morning I'm looking forward to hearing
more about open science and your
perspectives on how we as a community
can enable it and with that the floor is
yours
thanks Alex I'm very happy to be
speaking with this group today the term
open science is an unusual term because
it is essentially redundant right
scientific claims don't become credible
based on Authority or insistence that
they're true or logical arguments they
become credible based on the
availability of the evidence that
support the scientific claim so that
includes the outcome the report of what
the person is how they summarize how
they did their research and wived at
those Queens it includes the materials
and methodology that was the basis for
generating evidence or applying
analytics to the data that are generated
and the data itself that are the content
that supports that claim so the fact
that we have a discussion and unusual
term about open science isn't suggesting
something about a different way of doing
science but
rather the fact that the values of
openness and science are not consistent
necessarily with the daily practice of
how science is operating today so really
the open science movement is about
I think values in addressing the gap
between daily practice and core
principles of health sciences presumed
to operate so one way to start is to
just to review what are those core
principles of what makes science science
as a way of knowing as a way of learning
about the world and Robert Merton talked
about these in the 1940s and 50s when he
was trying to characterize the norms of
science or the values of science so one
he identified communality the open
sharing of information claims become
credible based on the sharing of the
evidence supporting those claims versus
the counting on secrecy well just got to
trust me on the scientist I know what
I'm talking about
just believe second Universalism
research is evaluated based on its own
merit right the evidence itself is the
basis of deciding whether the claims are
credible or not versus particularism a
value in research based on the authority
the prestige the eminence of the person
making the claim a third that Merton
identified was this interest in this
researchers are motivated by knowledge
and discovery forces the counter norm of
self-interested Innes just trying to get
ahead of the person down the hall
likewise researchers are consider all
new evidence even against prior work
organized skepticism versus the
countering line of ordinary dogmatism I
spend my career finding the initial
results and then fighting off all of the
attackers in your theall to defend my
particular point of view my theory my
findings and while Merton didn't talk
about it a lot of philosophers and
sociologists of science have talked
about a normal quality as a compared to
the counter normal quantity now those
may be easily recognizable values and
norms of how science is per scene but a
question is do actually researchers
endorse those norms do they buy in to
these as the values of science compared
to those counter norms that they could
buy them to Anderson and her colleagues
did a large-scale survey of NIH awardees
something like 3,300 people were in our
sample to see whether they endorsed the
counter norms or the norms and they this
graph here shows early career which
means people that were in a postdoctoral
award mid-career were folks that were in
their first r1 Awards so average age
around 40 and what I'm showing you is a
cumulative plot of the responses to that
survey where the gray indicates people
who endorsed the norms over the counter
norms on average whereas black are those
that endorse the counter norms over the
norms on average so you're seeing is 90%
or so of the participants in this survey
said that they endorsed those norms of
science over the counter norms and the
grey hatched lines are people that said
well I serve endorse spoken is equal so
there's broad endorsement for the norms
of science but then Anderson our
colleagues said okay that's fine don't
tell me what you endorse tell me how you
behave in your everyday research and it
looks like this so mostly still bored
with 60% of early in the career
researchers say that they behave
according to the norms of science but
many are acknowledging that those
counter norms of competition trying to
get ahead of keeping information
themselves of you know dogmatic thinking
are driving their behavior to some
degree and still most people do not
endorse
say that they don't behave according to
counter
over the norms then they said okay okay
don't tell me what you do as an
individual tell me what the people in
your area of research how do they behave
and the distribution of responses looks
like this
so most people perceive that their
community their culture around them
behaves more according to the counter
norms rather than the norms of science
and this is a challenging situation
because the gap between what my values
are those first graphs saying I want to
be open I want to be reproducible work I
want to be skeptical about my own work
versus what I perceive is reinforced is
incentivized is the dominant behavior in
my culture great - gap between how I
think science should be done and how I
think it is being done and what it takes
to be successful in the field and that's
a significant challenge and part of what
is characterized as the responsibility
crisis so whatever want to turn you want
to use that's been in discussion the
last few years is a lot of different
kinds of behaviors that may be good for
advanced one's own career making ones
research more publishable but not
necessarily good for the accuracy or the
reproducibility of the evidence and
there are lots and lots of research and
discussions about the various areas of
limitation in the quality or rigor or
reproducibility of work but we can
characterize some of the main ones like
this right low power most of the
investigations of the power of research
design suggest that we don't even have
enough power to detect the effects that
we are detecting increasing both the
likelihood of type 1 errors false
positive and type 2 errors false
negatives researchers have remarkable
flexibility in the kinds of analyses
that they do of the same data and then
can select among those which are the
analyses that are most favorable to
their interests whether that interest is
publication or their particular point of
view or whatever else I do many
experiments in my lab and only a subset
of them get into papers so what is that
process of selective reporting what ends
up getting filtered out and is that a
biasing influence over the reliability
of the work that's end up produce
but no results are considered less
interesting even less interpretable than
positive results leading to them being
more likely to be ignored or not
published or not even written up for
potential publication and the main
driver of scientific success is
innovation finding out new possibilities
what things could be true pushing new
areas of interested motivating
theoretical domains or really
possibilities and there are good
incentives for replication for verifying
findings that have been proposed for
increasing the reliability of the
estimates of effects that have been
observed and so as a consequence there's
lots and lots of innovation but without
practices of verification skepticism of
questioning of extending in incremental
accumulative ways now these are problems
that have been well discussed in the
literature and not just in the last five
or six years the references that I have
below are just a sample of the many
methodologists discussions about about
being very issues that occurred in the
1950s 60s and 70s and all of the
solutions that are being discussed now
for how we can increase reproducibility
are the same trays of solutions that
were identified during that time period
suggesting that we understand what the
problem is and what the solutions are we
just haven't developed a second
effective mechanisms for addressing it
and so at the Center for open science we
exist as a nonprofit technology company
that has a mission to increase openness
integrity reproducibility of research
and I want to just during this
presentation today give you an overview
of some of the activities that we have
for trying to nudge the practices of
science to be more aligned with those
core values so the the sort of a center
of what we think is the key challenge
for increasing openness and
reproducibility and research is that the
incentives for my success as a
practicing researcher are focused on me
getting it published not getting it
right so the mechanisms of reward my
likelihood of getting getting my job of
getting
of getting advanced in my career and at
least the easy way to characterize it is
depend on the publishing as frequently
as possible in the most prestigious
outlets that I can and not everything
get published so positive results are
more likely to publish their negative
results novel results more likely to be
published in replications or redundant
results and clean and tidy stories where
everything fits together in a nice
sequence are more likely to get
published than ones that have lots of
exceptions lots of things that are
uncertain positive novel clean results
are a gold mine those are the those are
the golden a be that we might shoot for
because those are more important better
results but of course in few
laboratories does that happen very often
right we don't get positive novel clean
and tidy results very easily because
we're studying problems that we don't
understand that's why we're studying
them and progress is helps
we get lots of exceptions lots of things
that don't make sense many things that
don't fit together lots of false starts
and that's just the process of doing
research that all the incentives are
pointing us to turning that group that's
happening in the lab into beautiful
stories at the end that show a clean and
tidy sequence that may be more beautiful
than the evidence actually supports and
that's where a lot of the key challenges
are is that the published literature may
appear to be more reliable more complete
more credible than the evidence
supporting it actually is because we
don't actually see all of the evidence
that has been generated and is being
used to make the prints that appear in
the little truth so there are a lot of
barriers to trying to address and make
all of that research process more
transparent so that it can be evaluated
by the research community for your
system to be able to do what's the
promise of researches which is to be
self-correcting we cannot self correct
if we don't know the basis of evidence
for the claims we can only self correct
based on what we can see and of course
the papers that come out of the research
process from my lab David Donnell with
Stanford characterized as advertising
for the research not research
so it's my best description of what I
think is important about the work that
we did that makes it as publishable as
possible and also makes it clear and
tidy and interesting to the reader but
of course the things behind it are where
the real research or the materials the
methodology the protocols the data all
of that work that is what generates a
search that's the real research itself
how can we make note of that accessible
so that the research community can be
self-correcting well there is a number
of important barriers one of them are
those precede norms that we just talked
about on the initial slide where I see
the culture being one of secrecy of
people advancing their careers of being
dogmatic in their approach and I don't
see myself wanting to do that but I have
I'm confronted with the choice I can
either include to the values that I have
wanting to do science as it's supposed
to be done but at the cost of career
advancement because I see that there are
other practices that are accelerating
people's careers or I could give in and
sacrifice some of those values and be
able to advance my career by doing some
of the behaviors that are more that a
better for career advancement you know
then that might not be better for
science that's a difficult situation for
anyone to be in second barriers that we
have these amazing frontal lobes that
give us lots of flexibility and
reasoning where when we're confronted by
multiple ways we could analyze the data
some of them look better for publication
and others multiple studies that we
could use to make it be the basis of our
clean some of us look better for
publication or for our existing theories
and others that we are likely to employ
or reasoning not as reasoning to arrive
at a conclusion or as rationalization to
justify a conclusion that we already
have and that is a lion's share of how
reasoning actually works is that we have
existing beliefs and we look for
information that helps to support our
existing beliefs our existing stakes so
that the employer things by confirmation
bias seeking information consistent with
our current points of view we employ
hindsight bias once we see results we
look at the results that have
best for us and so of course that's how
we would have done the study that's the
right kind of result to pay attention to
that's what I would have expected to
have occurred to all of those reasoning
strategies may unintentional without
really being aware that I'm employing
them maybe shaping the literature coming
out of my lab to look better than it
actually is
a third there is that a lot of that
happens with very little accountability
none of you know what happens in my lab
all you get to see other reports at the
end and so I don't have the conditions
the situation of perspective taking of
as we are reasoning through trying to do
our research thinking about how would an
observer evaluate the decisions that
were making here the decision to drop
that study to amplify that analysis to
suppress that analysis would they think
that that is a reasonable thing to do
and as we know from a lot of research on
accountability that perspective taking
or knowing that someone could observe
what I'm doing fundamentally changes how
I think about those problems what
decisions I make about what I'm going to
do how I'm going to do it and then
lastly we're very busy we're all very
busy and so the ideas of being more
transparent of making your data more
accessible of opening up our materials
our process of research all of those are
perceived and in reality many times as
an extra work as an appendage on the
existing workflows and if in a
competitive landscape like science in a
place where we are over committed
already with the variety of projects
that we're trying to pursue and
understand and do we are not likely to
be easily amenable to adding on new
things that we have to do in order to
make that research more accessible
especially if we're not incentivized to
do it if there's no reward for me making
my data and materials my protocols more
open and why would I spend that extra
time doing it even with the values of
desiring that as a good outcome so those
are formidable barriers and there's a
lot that needs to change in the culture
in order to try to address improvements
of openness and reproducibility as
ordinary practice
there are a few areas that the Center
for open science focus is on to try to
maximize the likelihood that we can move
to a more open and reproducible research
culture first strategy is that we are
primarily a technology company we have a
staff of 55 and about two-thirds of that
for command staff 55 are interns as well
but about two-thirds of that staff is
building tools like the Open Science
framework to enable researchers to be
more open with no research we also
provide training as many others do for
how to be more open and reproducible in
research practices and then the third is
providing some means of shifting nudging
those incentives that drive our behavior
through funders through journals through
institutions so that researchers have a
reason to embrace moving toward more
world and practices so I'd like to do
for the rest of the time that we have is
to summarize some of our activities of
these and then we'll be delighted to
have some questions and discussion about
what other barriers or what
opportunities there are to try to align
scientific values and practices more
closely let me start with to the
big-picture view of how do we shift
incentives given the cultural challenges
that we face in science and we can
characterize this in very simple terms
of a psychology 101 perspective on
scientific behavior and that is to think
about what are the means with which
researchers get the rewards that they
get and those being primary drivers of
behavior so right now my primary means
of getting the key reward publications
are focused on the outcomes of the
research the things that we do in the
lab and we're likely we are to have
novel positive clean results the more
likely I am to get that reward that I
need publication and publication
prestigious outputs so if this is the
singular model of incentive of reward
then everything hinges on outcomes on
producing amazing sexy exciting results
and everything else is essentially
irrelevant to how it is I advance in my
career so how do we change that model so
that it isn't just
reward system well one obvious thing to
do is add additional means so instead of
adjusting rewarded on the outcomes that
I produce can we also nudge those
incentives so that sometimes important
part I'm rewarded on the process by
which I pursue those outcomes right the
quality of my methodologies
accessibility the transparency of that
methodology evidence the reproducibility
of the process by which I generate my
findings if those can also be a
mechanism over work then it isn't just
the outcomes although we will never get
rid of outcomes because people who
discover more amazing things will be
rewarded more than people who don't but
we can add additional means of getting
rewards so that the process also is part
of career advancement likewise we can
diversify the rewards so it isn't just
getting publication and having the
Journal article be the sole mechanism of
advancement but also the generation of
important research trinket right
so a person who generates an amazingly
important data set should be rewarded
for that as a scholarly unit of its own
the data being a mechanism of scholarly
advancement and materials the analytic
scripts and code that are generated are
themselves scholarly contributions and
could be credited as such rather than
having it solely be through the getting
your name on a paper and particularly
getting you named first or last on that
paper so most of our strategies are
thinking about ways to diversify means
and rewards across the existing
incentive structures that drive
researchers behaviors today so let's
start with an example that's a trivially
easy or simple one and that is to signal
desirable behaviors so this is an
example of badges to reward open
practices so we develop these badges and
there's a committee of researchers from
a variety of different fields that help
maintain the specifications for what
needs to have open data or open
materials or have pre-registered your
research design defined in advance what
they're doing how to do it a journal can
adopt these badges
and when my paper gets accepted to
invite me to say would you like any of
these badges to be attached to your
paper and so it appears there and if you
can meet the specifications then you get
the badge and then there will be a link
for example with open data to how
someone can access your data in an
independent wall story now badges are
silly they're a trivial thing but the in
this case they are signals of something
that's valued in the research community
openness and value but no one knows when
someone else is being open in their
practices right there aren't any signals
for doing those extra things to be more
open and transparent in one's work and
so providing a signal of evidence that
someone is doing the desirable behavior
especially when it's not easy to see
otherwise could be a powerful shift very
simple but powerful shift in the
incentives that drive individual
researchers behaviors they may be more
willing to do those extra steps just to
be able to signal that they care about
these issues that they are pursuing open
practices so we worked with the journal
Psychological Science to as the first
journal that adopted badges and they
adopted in January 1st 2014 what I'm
showing you here is an investigation of
the effect of badges this new policy of
offering badges at psychological science
compared to for comparison journals in
psychology and the y-axis is showing the
percent of articles for every half year
from 2012 through the end of 2013 for
the % of articles that said that data
were available in an independent
repository and Psychological Science and
black shows about 3 percent of their
articles on average each half year now
were data available in a repository and
the other journals likewise had low
amounts so then psychological science
adopts badges January 1st 2014 and then
this is what happens so by the first
half of 2015 39 percent of the articles
in psychological science had open data
in the independent repository and the
only change was the introduction of this
policy with the opportunity to apply for
a badge on the Artic
that has no implications other than
signaling to their others in your
research community that you did this
particular practice so it is a trivial
change but it had an ordinary strong
impact on behavior 14 fold increase in
the rates of data sharing at least in
this example and so that it isn't
magical abilities in any particular way
it's just leveraging the fact that these
values already exist as I showed you on
that first slide of Anderson and her
colleagues people already engaged
endorsed the normal openness they're
just not rewarded for behaving that way
and so by providing a simple signal that
can dramatically increase people's
likelihood of adhering to the values
that they already have and and and doing
so in the sector claims
okay so that's one example to introduce
the next example I want to just give a
research example of this challenge of
selective reporting and how it can make
the published literature look more
credible than it is and there's lots of
good research examples in clinical
trials and other fields this this
example comes from the social sciences
and what I'm showing you here is a
comparison of studies that were pre
registered and what the methodology was
going to be done versus what was
actually reported in the paper that came
out in the end
so any Franco and her colleagues took
advantage of a NSF funded project called
test this is time series experiments in
social sciences and what test is is a
coordinated effort to give researchers
in disciplines access to a
representative sample of adults to do
experiments those are very precious
samples but hard to get and recruit and
maintain and so this is a valued
resource and so what researchers in the
field can do is they can design their
protocol and then they submit it to
tests for peer review and if it's
accepted then test runs that protocol on
this sample of representative sample
versus adults and then send you the data
the condition for the researchers for
getting access to this is a free
resource is that you have to make your
protocol public and the data public so
that others can review it and so what
this creates is this opportunity to see
what was actually in the research
because we almost never in basic and
preclinical sciences almost never know
what the precise methodology was just
what was in the report versus what I
loved in the report what do they say
they get in their project and so what
I'm showing you on the left here on the
x-axis is the number of experimental
conditions or treatment times they were
actually in the study from zero to five
in the question area in the data as it
was collected and the y-axis is the
number of experimental conditions or
treatment ons that were reported in the
paper where they said that these
conditions did occur and what you can
see is that if every paper reported all
of the conditions that were in the
experiments and all of the dots would be
on the diagonal line but 40% of the
studies in this case left out one or
more of the experimental conditions just
didn't mention that they had occurred in
the paper even though they had occurred
in protocol on the panel on the right is
the same thing but now with the outcome
variables so on the x-axis is showing
the number of outcome variables and were
actually in the experiment as it was
conducted and on the y-axis is the
number of outcome variables that we
reported in the paper at the end in the
published article 70% of the articles
left out one or more of the outcome
variables that was actually in this
study now it's possible that happens
that happens for a lot of different
reasons and it may not become sequential
if there's no particular bias in what's
likely to be reported in the paper
versus what's likely to be left out but
because this was open data Franco and
her colleagues were able to follow up
and look at what was included in what
was excluded from the paper and what
they found was that for the 122 reported
tests that were included in the paper
the median p-value was 0.02 so they were
positive results write to you less than
0.05 is the standard metric for deciding
whether you obtain a positive result
the median effect size was point to nine
so almost the third of a standard
deviation approximately and 63% of the
results that were reported with positive
results so then they went because they
have the access to the raw data to the
result the outcome variables at work
reported and what they observed is that
there were a hundred forty seven of
those the median p-value is 0.35 the
effect size was 0.1 3 less than half and
only 23% of those were significant
effects so this suggests that there is a
substantial bias in what outcomes are
likely to get report in the paper
positive outcomes compared to the
outcomes that were actually of urine
suggesting that the reported research
that the papers at the end were more
beautiful more clean better sorts then
the data actually suggested that's a
significant challenge and only
identifiable because we can tell the
difference between what was planned at
the outset and what was done and
reported at the end and this is related
to a very important distinction in the
philosophy of science which is two
different modes of research right in one
mole we are in the context of
justification we have a hypothesis that
we want to acquire beta to test and so
this in hypothesis testing mode you're
in confirmatory approach to analysis
right we are laying out of hypotheses a
methodology a way we're going to analyze
the data that we obtain from that
methodology and then we go out to get
data and then confront our hypothesis
with the data so the decisions in this
case about the hypothesis and the
analysis plan are independent of the
data itself you don't get to know what
the data are because you have to make
your commitments so what your hypothesis
and how you would analyze it in advance
in order to confront that hypothesis the
other mode of analysis is were more in
the context of discovery where we're
using data in order to generate
hypotheses we're getting in the in the
wings and looking at data where we don't
have a clear sense of a hypothesis or a
overall theory and we're exploring that
in order to see where things might occur
so that once we can generate those
hypotheses which we have ideas we can
then
later confront them do a different study
in order to test those hypotheses those
decisions in the context of exploration
or data contingent we're using is inform
how we are analyzing the data the
importance of this distinctive is it was
important for a number of reasons but
there is a practice it is central to
make it clear when we're in one mode of
analysis or the other and both of these
modes are critical for scientific
advancement and the key payment
pre-registration does is clarify when we
are in the context of discovery versus
the context of justification because
mixing these two up has important
implications so why is this crustacean
important well the typical tools of
statistical inference using p-values for
example in null hypothesis significance
testing are interprete below in the
context of confirmation where you know
precisely the number and kind of
influence tests you are going to do and
then can apply corrective processes for
the number of tests first likelihood of
them being false positives but when
we're in the context of discovery when
we're making choices contingent on the
beta G values lose their diagnostic they
don't have the informative meaning that
they have because there are many
possible analyses we could have done
that we either did do and ignored or
didn't do because we didn't think to do
them given what we saw in the data
itself Andrew Gelman for example calls
this the Garden of forking paths when
you're confronted with many
possibilities as you observe the data
many of those pens wither away very
easily quickly and never pursue them
if you hadn't known the big you might
have pursued those tests and so the that
causes the the fact that the p-values
are not interpret Lin that contestar
non-diagnostic increases the likelihood
of false discoveries when you're an
exploratory mode when you're using
p-values to draw inferences so the key
challenge for not forcing via
pre-registration when during the context
of justification versus discovery in
that presenting exploratory results as
confirmatory
is the publish ability right I see more
positive results I get more interested
in those I start to draw interpretations
and theories that explain those but at
the cost of the credibility of the
likelihood that they are false positives
and not aligned with reality so the only
ideal model of how the search operates
because we're doing all of these three
mechanisms is one where we would
generate a study rate we do studies for
some reason and we write down why is it
that we are doing the spending what is
the purpose of this study what are we
trying to find or infer and many times
we get into a new domain with very
little idea of where it might go but we
have some idea so it may be a very
simple we're going to try this one thing
to start but really this is an
exploratory investigation so we write
down what that is we commit to that in
advances or very constraining of what
we're testing as a hypothesis and this
is now routine in my lab we pre-register
everything once we've analyzed the data
in that very simple way that we started
then we take that data set and we
explore the heck out of it we move into
exploratory mode of analysis where we
are trying to now unpack this phenomenon
where we had some interesting questions
but we had very little idea of what
direction to go and that exploratory
mode of analysis gives us now some ideas
some hypotheses but we can start to
start to shake the phenomenon that we're
investigating but then inspires the next
study and in that study we can
pre-register our design now that we have
some hypotheses pre-register what we're
going to do to test that and how we're
going to analyze it and then move right
back into exploratory mode once we
discover how long we were that 22 and
then back and forth and back and forth
so this concept prove discretion is well
known now in clinical sciences because
it's work law for certain types of
clinical trials but it is relatively
unknown and certainly not practiced in
most basic and preclinical areas of
research and even though the value may
be seen as clear but there is lack of
familiarity because it often is
disruptive to the work zones that we
have for how it is we do our research
whether it's
experimental data collections whether
it's working with existing datasets or
otherwise there are lots of different
ways in which we can create with better
distinctions between our confirmatory
and exploratory modes of analysis so one
initiative that we have to try to
promote awareness and education about
the value of pre-registration it's
called the pre-registration challenge
and you can visit it at the link here
the idea of the pre-registration
challenge is that we are giving a
thousand one thousand dollar awards to
the first thousand researchers that
publish the results of a pre registered
study in eligible journal really the
goal for this is an awareness and
education campaign so when you go to the
website you get lots of information
about what pre-registration is how it
works
some background reading materials
process information and then there's a
guided workflow that helps researchers
sort of take the steps for how they can
pre-register their study and actually
walk them through pre-registration of a
research design and then a very rapid
review process to confirm that all of
the things that were were pre registered
and then the person goes ahead and does
their research so our suspicion
expectation is that once researchers try
pre-registration for the area of work
because it's a high barrier to initiate
because it is a disruption to the
ordinary workflow but once they try it
it is relatively likely to become a
habit because very quickly one can
experience the benefits of
pre-registration I mentioned before that
my lab does pre-registration for all the
research we do now and the benefits are
very high because we do a lot more
upfront planning and identification of
problems before we actually initiate
data collection so we end up being more
efficient not less because of that
planning process we've had a number of
times where we thought we had a design
that was going to be effective for
testing the hypothesis that we were
looking to investigate in the first
place and then discover we had some flaw
in the design it wouldn't have allowed
us to test it the way that we wanted so
having done that in advance and actually
writing it down writing down our
analysis plan confronts us with that
about the waste of the data collection
and likewise for those areas of research
where there's a lot of variations a
paradigm attic approach in a methodology
pre-registration that's very efficient
because we pre-register we develop a
note protocol for one study and then we
just adapt it incrementally with the
experiments as they go through the
sequence of research that we do so
that's something that's worth trying out
if they have any interest at all those
other related initiative that really
tries to get into the incentives that
researchers have driving them now in
that publication process and that's this
one is called registered reports and you
can go to the link there to find out
more information so the contour the
context of register reports this is the
cartoon version of how we do research
design of study collect and analyze the
data write up a report and object but of
course it's not that simple there is
that barrier of peer review that's in my
way from once I finished that report to
actually publishing it now in this
standard model the all the incentives
for me to get publication that I need
are making that report as likely as
possible to make it through peer review
so I need it to be a novel story means
to be clean and nice any positive
results everything that peer reviewers
will not hate I have to do and try to
get that report into as good as possible
likewise for peer reviewers their
incentives are tied in to their
commitments to the findings that I'm
reporting if I'm in a contentious area
of research and I get peer reviewers
that like what I found
they will also like the methodology that
reinforces their worldview whereas if
they don't like what I found if it
challenges a particular find in the bay
pad or a particular perspective then
they may be much more likely to identify
all kinds of problems in the methodology
reinforcing their negative view of the
results itself so what register reports
does is shift these incentives by making
one simple change to the review process
and that is moving peer review at the
journal to right after the design phase
so what I do it as an author when I
submit a registered report to a journal
is I submit the research question the
method or the background for why that's
an important question and the
methodology that I'm going to use to
test that question and I might have some
preliminary experiments for example
showing the viability of the approach or
something aha but the but the results
are not known because those experiments
have not been done and the peer
reviewers evaluate the quality of the
question the importance of the question
and the quality of the methodology
context that question you need to know
the answers and if this methodology
effective efficient form to be a good
way to evaluate the outcomes of this
research and then if that passes peer
review the journal gives an incredible
acceptance to paper so I say we will
publish this regardless whether it's a
positive or negative or as long as did
the MIT or through with the method all
of you you didn't just and actually get
that either it's absent so they're just
incentives for other buddies in the
process just enough so it's all about
getting a publication that's how the
that's how the world works that were in
now but the incentives for the of an
author are focused on asking the most
support the questions that I can and
developing the most robust methodology
that can to test them incentive so peer
reviewers or now how can I evaluate this
methodology but also my feedback instead
of saying what you did wrong as you
should have done and experiments already
finished now my feedback is how can I
improve your experiment and so as an
author I can feel more grateful to
reviewers for identifying problems at
this stage because I have an opportunity
to actually fix them in a methodology
before the experiments are doing and so
it makes the process much more
collaborative
the so far we have 50 journals I think
that have adopted this as a publishing
option in addition to the con
traditional process conversant and both
it can be a comprehensive replacement
because there's a lot of things that are
real discoveries there aren't things
that are anticipated in advance you
don't design the study to do but you get
left turn all of a sudden in doing
research and a lot of those will appear
in the normal publication process as it
occurs now or would be things that
happened in the introduction for one of
these kinds of papers and then you do a
follow-up experiment to really nail that
phenomenon that came out of the blue
during that line of research okay so
those examples have give you badges in
pre-registration challenge and
registered reports or some efforts to
try to nudge a variety of the different
incentives so that researchers are the
warded for being open in their practices
and trying to present practices that are
likely to increase the reproducibility
of their work and trying to fit those in
to the existing reinforcements and
reward systems that researchers are
living by the other half or most of what
we spend our time on is the technology
develop the support researchers to be
more open in the research and so I want
to spend the rest of the time that I
have to give you an overview of what
we're trying to do with the technology
to sort of support the shift towards
more open practices and really that at
the core of this is not as a very simple
idea for how we can improve research and
that is one that was instructed to us in
kindergarten for how we should behave
and that is to show our work and to
share there is very little else that we
really needed to do at a system level I
think to improve research practices one
of the great things about science is
that it's an open marketplace of ideas
people are feeding ideas in skeptical
others readiness challenge them
extending them and we're using them
transforming them and over time some
stuff pops out of that blue of
marketplace
as surviving as getting through that
skeptical process and having some value
beyond just the exploration of the idea
itself for that process to work
efficiently the main thing that we need
to know is what what are the basis of
people's claims how are they arriving at
those claims so that I can actually
pratik them so that the process can self
correct because without access to the
background information we don't know how
to self-correct don't know how to
critique novel findings as effectively
as we can and so if nothing else if we
can make that process more accessible
and more transparent more open then self
correction will work as we imagine it
all coded so that openness for our from
our perspective applies to 20 different
areas of practice open access is very
familiar right papers baking papers more
accessible to more people rather than
being behind for example subscription
services open data is a very prominent
and ongoing discussion now is how do we
make the content of our research the
data the materials the protocols the
code more accessible to others but a
critical fold piece that isn't yet and
since the discussion is open work flow
the process by which I generate those
data and process by which I analyze
those data and draw inference and we
make that more accessible for others
because that process like
pre-registration is just as important as
the data itself to understand the basis
of claims that come out of it so all
three of those are part of the various
approaches to building technology
infrastructure tools to help researchers
do their research and all of this is
organized through the Open Science
framework and that's at OSF that I owe
all of the tools we build a free and
open source and grow of exclusively
public goods and the Open Science
framework is a scholarly Commons that
has as its first mission to help
researchers manage their own research
for their own use privately so when you
go real access you can sign up for an
account when you have an account you can
easily create projects while you add
toriel's and data things that you're
working on on those projects - those
those are all then stored in cloud base
or cable services you can add
collaborators to those projects so that
they have access to those workspaces as
well and all of that can be done
privately so with the OSF you never have
to make anything public if you don't
want to and the problem that we're
trying to solve with this infrastructure
by allowing this privacy is researchers
maintaining their own data and materials
for their own use right the person that
loses the most information for my
research is me because we have lots of
different projects in the lab there's
lots of people coming in and out of the
lab postdocs and graduate students and
research assistants and when one person
needs and one computer guys a lot of
information is with them and so what the
OSS phones is that archival problem is a
cloud-based solution where every project
is stored for the lab in that space and
it also has a collected knowledge base
so that postdoc Williams I don't lose
because of that person
ad hoc organization system I don't need
the information the data the source
materials the notebook the electronic
notebook etc I don't need that
information because that person is going
to so the key though is we solved that
problem trying to make a it's online
resource a repository for one's labs own
use while then simultaneously making it
trivial make parts or all of that more
accessible others make it open so on
every project and every component of
every project there's a little button so
make public and if I click that button
it says are you sure you want to make
that public and if I say yes then that
part of the project is public and so by
that we have integrated private and
public workflows so that my lab can be
doing its research and we may have a
longitudinal project that we're going to
do for many years and we're not ready to
make the data set available but we are
ready to sort of make some of the
materials other people can use these
materials or they might have ideas for
collaborations that they see some of the
methodology that we're pursuing so in at
that part of the project public while we
continue to work with the other parts
privately in the OSS with just the
collaborators
so the idea is to reduce the barriers to
openness to be trivial members right not
add on to people's workflow and make it
a pen for their work busy work days but
rather provide a tool that has value for
maintaining their own research for the
norm use and make it easy to integrate
that private workflow management with
making things publicly accessible at the
core of the Ola set is an API to connect
services around the entire research
lifecycle and so once a particular
service is connected to the old set then
that service is connected to all of the
other services that are already
connected in USM so these are the
services that are connected as of today
Zotero and Mendeley citation management
services data storage like Google Drive
box comm Dropbox Amazon Web enzone s3
get held for code Jaz stats for data
analysis and then other archival
environments like say shared data verse
and then we also have a number of other
ones that are in development now through
grants that we provided to variety of
different groups to connect their
service the idea for this is one that we
can help researchers get around their
research lifecycle more efficiently with
less loss of information by connecting
all the services that they use together
and by connecting those services make
researchers more efficient getting
around the lifecycle but also decrease
the likelihood of error of information
going in and out of the different
services that use the analytics platform
with where it's towards with how they
visualize their day with writing up for
publication etc so if we can minimize
error and increase efficiency getting on
the lifecycle and researchers win and
get more efficient in doing their work
and by connecting all these services
together larger collaborative teams can
use the same set of services even only a
subset of them actually make use of them
right so I might use github because I'm
familiar with command learning code but
one of my collaborators might not use
github but by representing in the OSS a
simplified interface I can still give
those collaborators access to the code
and switch that we're using without them
having to be a regular user of the
service and then a byproduct of all of
that
that the entire process the entire
research life cycle is more reproducible
because as we've connected these
together we can log what happens
actually follow the craft the process of
doing research in order to make the
entire thing more reproducible overall
so another example so this is an open
API public API so anybody can connect
their services and the goal is to make
it for that any kind of service that
supports research can be connected to
the lifecycle so for example the
research computing Center at Notre Dame
has a computational services or engine
that they use to support the researchers
they connected that to the OSF and by
connected to the OSF then instead of
having to negotiate developing API
relationships with each individual
repository once it was connected a OSF
then Notre Dame users of that
computational platform could apply data
that's stored in any environment that's
already connected you assess whether
it's on Dropbox or Amazon s3 or in an
own cloud so this or box.com or
otherwise and so the benefits can be
rapidly to scale by connecting
particular services that support one's
own air and research the other key part
of the OSF is that it is a layered
system so that those core services at
the base here the ecosystem of
connecting services together the data
upon which it's all collected and then
the services authentication security
management workflow rendering in the
browser all those things are modularized
in components so that they can be put
together in a variety of different ways
but with different interfaces applied to
them so the OSF is one interface to
access all of those different services
and all of that data and workflow
management but you can build any
interface on top of that core set of
services because it's completely
modernized from how the information is
visualized so one of those one example
of that just to illustrate is a
generalized print print service that we
have developed and I'll show you some
images up in a second and that's at the
second layer and then that served
is modularized so that it can be branded
for any community to run their own
version of that service and so with the
preprint service we have ten or eleven
now different groups that either penny
they launched or soon to launch their
own preprint service all built on the
OSF and done so very efficiently and by
this layering we can enable scholarly
communities to focus on the areas of
expertise that they have so for example
photo archive an open archive for the
social scientists is run by sociologists
and they care very much about the
content of the research in the pre booth
and the and their research community
that is using preprints what they aren't
expert and don't really care about how
security is managed in this or the kind
of databases are used that's less the
technical experts care without the focus
they're individually and then scholarly
communication experts who think about
information transmission and how
preprint services can get designed focus
their efforts on designing that
interface layer between them and then
the content area experts focus on just
delivery of the service and engaging
their scholarly community and so this
really provides a great deal of
flexibility for the research community
to be able to employ the same set of
scholarly tools following comments for a
lot of different uses it can open up
more of a research life cycle so
preprints our way to make research more
accessible to more people more quickly
and so if you go to OSF that IO slash
preprints you can find the general
search infrastructure and this is an
aggregated search across a variety of
different preprint services whether
they're hosted by the Center for open
science or not and you can search
against all of those in a single
interface and then simultaneously each
of those individual services has their
own URL and place for them to manage
their own service so that they can run
preprints on their own so if anybody's
interested inspiring a preprint service
please do contact we're happy to engage
you on watching a preprint service for
for your community
and I'm going to close so that there's a
couple minutes for questions but just to
give an illustration of OSF institutions
as another view of that same set of core
tools I mentioned that Notre Dame Center
for research computing computational
service connection as an example but
institutions can sign up for OSF as an
institutional service it's free service
for institutions to and then make it
easy for their researchers to get onto
the service single sign-on capacity so
people can use their university
credentials and they can connect
whatever services that they have in
their research environment like an
institutional repository to the OSF to
make access of those services more
efficient within their research
community there are variety of different
institutions that are already using OSF
institutions this is just to illustrate
so let me close with that because there
may be some questions and there's a few
minutes left but just two points you see
some links where if you'd like to follow
up with information to use any of these
services I didn't talk about training
but we have free trainings that can be
done remotely or in person on open or
reproducible practices and we are a
service organization so if you have a
service that you use you want to connect
the OSF if you have a community that
you'd like to have make use of Gillis F
or get involved in the pre reg challenge
or or if your journal editor want to
pursue register reports as a pilot for
your journal just feel free to get in
touch with us for any of these things
and here are links and if you google my
name I come up there aren't many no sex
in the world so happy to chat so thanks
very much for your time the attention I
really appreciate
fine thanks so much for this great talk
um we do have actually you've got a lot
of questions I'm gonna try and
synthesize a few of them together and
maybe we can get through one or two of
them obviously the badge system that
you've proposed here and described cut a
lot of interest and I think there's one
or two questions around well actually
there's some questions around that but
maybe one or two key ones one is is it
possible to apply the badges
retrospectively or retro actively to
work that's already published and how
far back we could we go if that was
possible and secondly how it abstracts
services or indexing services like
national library of medicine's uh PubMed
or MEDLINE support that is do you think
would it be possible to for instance to
add something like that to their their
search mechanisms or they're there as a
filter so let's start with those two
questions first yeah yeah great
questions
and the answer is yes possible for both
and not active for those so anybody can
be a badge issuer and one of the things
that we is in development isn't in
production yet there's a badge bakery so
that the badge itself is embedded in it
metadata about who has an issue or what
was it issue for you know if there's a
DOI inserting the DUI etc and that is to
provide as much flexibility as possible
for these different current abuses
retrospective prospective different
groups applying badges and then make
them machine readable excuse me and
recoverable across a variety of
different issuers so yes that's possible
and also for the latter point on getting
badges integrated with with NLM or other
services we're very interested in
pursuing those kinds of solutions
because the real power of things like
badges are when they move to scale right
it's great to show an example in a
single journal but really the the
practice as a normative practice and
especially getting integrated with
things like one CD and other mechanisms
of reward right and consume it to your
instance
Dushan what portion of your data is
openly accessible for others as a
mechanism of indicating good process
that will only work when it moves to
scale and so we're very interested in in
pursuing collaborations like with NLM
and other groups for that rate so maybe
one last question before it before we go
and this is more of a sort of personal
question as as a couple people have
asked this but as a leader in this field
what was the moment that sort of got you
into open science what was what was the
the lightbulb or the point in time which
users thought then saw that this was it
this was a key issue yeah I suspected my
experiences like a lot of people's where
I didn't realize that science wasn't
open when I started in it and so it was
only when I got into grad school and I
took a methodology class with Alan
Kazdin my first year where I realized
yeah we read all of these papers in the
60s and 70s all these challenges of how
science is done and what the reality is
and I'm sort of stunned by that right oh
I thought it was sort of like how we
talked about in second grade you know
I'm curious without a question and I
study it and then I write down what I
did and I share that with other people
and then they say oh what about this
what about that and the fact that it
doesn't operate like that was sort of an
awakening my lab in grad school and in
my labs because I've been a faculty
member a coily had a technical part of
the lab always just built tools to try
to make our research more efficient and
more useful and more accessible so I
sort of said we we can make our own
betta more available even if we can't
good even if the field wasn't operating
that way but and so we've always had
that have always been applying for
grants that try to increase build tools
to make things more accessible but the
actual you know the development of the
Center for open science which is a
spin-out from my lab really was sort of
a not a planned but sort of a grasping
at an opportunity that sort of appeared
so I didn't talk about our
reproducibility projects but we've done
some large-scale replication projects of
studies in psychology first my
field and we have one ongoing now in
cancer biology and we started to do that
replication project just as a lab
project one for psychology at the same
time that we were building sort of an
initial version of the Open Science
framework and that got a lot of press
attention and then Thunder started
calling and our primary funder of the
Laura and John Arnold foundation gave us
a five and a quarter million dollar
award in order to start the center and
so what was sort of aspirations that
were realistic
wouldn't it be great if we could build
some tools that helped a few people
turned into oh my gosh we could really
start an organization maybe really push
on this let's go for it
and for that was you know that gift just
really changed the direction of how we
did this okay well we're it time so it's
10 o'clock on the west coast so again
Brian thank you for it for your
wonderful insights on this it was it was
inspirational to hear a lot of this work
and we'll end this session here thank
you very much and I appreciate everybody
attending